I recently had a lot of fun making
simulations for how the electric field
responds to a moving charge it was all
for a longer video on YouTube that
covers the fundamentals of what light is
but here I just thought I'd share with
you some of the pretty animations that
came out of it the full electric field
is threedimensional it Associates each
point in space with a little Vector
telling you what force would be applied
to a unit charge if it were sitting at
that point in Space the 3D fields are
fun to look at but they are a bit busy
so often it's easier to just show a
slice of that field say on the XY plane
in the main video I talk about the
underlying law used to make these
simulations it's not actually Maxwell's
equations which are the fundamental laws
underlying electricity and magnetism
instead I'm coding in another
intermediate law something that you can
derive from Maxwell's equations but
which is a little easier to wrap your
mind around both for the sake of making
the animations and also for the sake of
the student trying to understand what's
going
[Music]
on